annie girardot dans docteur françoise
gailland et dans cette scène aux côtés
de michel subor et de joséphine chaplin
je vous félicite vous ai pas vus depuis
cette soirée
je vous félicite je suis au nom de
l'équipe des rendez vous du dimanche
vous savez que nous avons une attention
particulière pour tout ce que vous
faites et je suis très content qu'on
vous ait remis ce césar ô combien
méritée quelle est votre réaction quand
vous voyez cette scène vous avez déjà
oublié ce film un point du tout non non
je ne vais jamais les choses heureuses
et puis même l'hymne allemand est enfin
surtout celle ci je veux dire que c'est
une histoire combative du départ alors
le résultat c'est une récompense mais ce
qu'il y avait des failles ans dans cette
récompense si vous n'étiez pas prévenu
donc vous a convoqué vous êtes dans la
salle
ah oui mais ces deux c'est normal c'est
ce que je faisais c'était exactement le
sport je veux dire que je ne sais pas si
je l'aurais où je n'aurais pas et alors
je me disais mon dieu si je ne les ai
pas je vais pas essayer de faire
mauvaise mais c'est comme ça et puis et
puis on l'a et puis allez on vous
appelle et puis je crois que j'ai été
très ému parce que finalement j'ai été
plus que par le prix j'ai été touché par
le la gentillesse de enfin aborder un
processus leur session qui m'avait
ces teneurs et puis aussi par l'accueil
du public et j'ai été profondément
touché véritablement et je vraiment je
dis pas que je n'enrichis calais parce
que toujours les faits ça s'est senti
d'ailleurs et la concurrence était
sévère il y avait dix à belhadj année
mieux mieux et romy schneider ou droit
très bonne actrice mais fait très
plaisir aussi c'est de retrouver et romy
nous ayons connue au monde rocco et nous
voyons beaucoup à ce moment-là et et de
la voir là avec moi et en plus on s'est
fait un gros bisou et ça m'a beaucoup
touché
alors depuis françoise gailland ya les
filles beaucoup les sous les ponts vous
avez beaucoup travaillé vous avez tourné
court après moi que je t'attrape où il
vit à chacun son enfer de films très
difficile et je ne peux pas m'empêcher
de repenser une conversation tout
amoureux il ya quelques années et où
vous m'aviez dit j'ai envie de tout
plaquer
oui on a toujours envie de tout plaquer
c'est vrai pas au moment où ça
fonctionne bien mais on a des moments où
ça fonctionne bien finie moment ça ne
fonctionne pas du tout et puis
évidemment on peut décourager
je les dis
non je l'avais dit après françoise
gailland et en plus surtout après le
film de cayatte parce que ce sont des
films assez dramatique je voulais plus
après françois ii l'ayant touché quelque
chose j'étais mourir d'aimer
non mais je l'avais pas dit à ce moment
les dix après françoise gailland aussi
mon dieu on n'a pas tellement envie de
l'interpréter des choses comme ça tous
les jours moi j'aime bien rire et puis
et la vie est belle et voilà mais bon et
puis j'ai fait le film de cayatte qui
est je crois le film le plus dramatique
que j'ai fait voilà je voulais dire à ce
propos que je n'étais pas venu le
défendre puisque j'étais quand il est
vous étiez solidaire particules mort
mais que solidaires les uns grévistes
je voulais pas parler de cayatte mais je
voulais dire une chose qui me tenait
beaucoup à ce propos c'est que je sais
que c'est un film très dur
c'est une histoire affreuse c'est vrai
mais je pense que monsieur khayat a
voulu faire un film qui était d'égaler
le sujet je crois qu'on n'a pas très
bien compris qu'elle était sujet je
crois que le sujet important dans le
film de cayatte c'était le l'histoire
d'une mère double c'est à dire une mère
victime et une mère coupable puisqu'elle
est la mère de la salsa donc c'était
ceux qui avaient voulu faire payer à
tous voilà ça n'a peut-être pas été très
bien compris mais enfin c'était ça le
problème du film puisque vous parlez de
cayatte dans l'article que vous consacre
paris match sous la plume de françois
pédron cas yade déclare qu' il a
toujours été fasciné par votre
disponibilité et par votre votre façon
de vous éloigner d'oublier complètement
le film quand vous n'êtes pas
directement concerné par une scène là je
vous ai vu dans une scène dramatique
docteur françoise gailland ne parlons
pas d'achat qu'un son enfer et kayak dit
ce qu'il ya d'extraordinaire avec annie
girardot c'est que elle est capable de
jouer une scène avec une intensité
parfois bouleversantes puis dès la scène
terminée elle retrouve ses mots croisés
alors ça je peux pas comprendre ça
j'adore encore plus faire des pauses
mais là ça doit faire du tricot par
contre il m'a dit une chose qui est très
juste et qui est pour tous les comédiens
il m'a dit tu vois année tu as une bonne
santé parce qu'il faut une bonne santé
pour faire ce métier
voilà mais est-ce qu'on sort vraiment
intact d'un rôle comme celui qu'on vous
a confié à chacun son enfer mais bien
sûr je veux dire qu'il y a une histoire
dramatique il ya un cas bien sûr qu'il
était un peu disons grossi parce que
quand même dans la vie à une femme live
on lui retire son enfant on lui rend
mort et en plus le deuxième enfant a tué
le 1er évidemment c'est un petit peu dur
à avaler
cela dit c'est ce qu'a dit khayat c'est
une tragédie qu donc c'est l'essence
même d'un drame et il fallait le
développer
je sais très bien que les miens je fais
des corps va bien je veux dire mais on a
à raconter une histoire il était
évidemment difficile de surtout dans le
film de kaya de de pouvoir oublier ça
mais en même temps on l'oubli parce
qu'il faut l'oublier mais en même temps
il faut pas perdre le fil